[Musique]
samedi soir tf1 diffusait la 22e édition
des nrj music awards
une édition exceptionnelle que vides
oblige en effet les missions se
déroulait à paris enfin à boulogne
billancourt à la scène musicale nrj
music awards par action une émission qui
n'avait donc pas lieu à cannes
exceptionnellement et qui se déroulait
sans public n'y avait pas de public est
tout pour moi mais chez qui sont
derrière résultat si le public était
absent plusieurs stars ont tout de même
assuré le show c'est le cas de vita et
slimane les grands gagnants de la soirée
qui sont repartis avec plusieurs
récompenses que si on nous avait dit
qu'on n'en gagnerait 5 me 2,3 dans
serment n'y croit pas on ne croyait pas
d'adjoint quant à lui été sacré artiste
masculin francophone de l'année
et aya nakamura été couronnée artiste
francophone féminine de l'année
surprise de cette édition la présence de
squeeze le youtuber le plus populaire de
france faisait partie des lauréats grâce
à son album hope 6 sorti en décembre
dernier une édition particulière des nrj
music awards qui a rassemblé 5 millions
92 mille téléspectateurs et 22 3% du
public
arrivant derrière france 3 et la
rediffusion de sa série mon jeu ville
voilà vous avez battu tous les records
un artiste absents fo direct émission
sans public
on peut dire que cette édition 2020 aura
déçu des téléspectateurs alors nma 2020
la pire cérémonie de l'histoire lui la
voix il ya un petit peu race là il y va
à fond ça fait quand même cinq millions
c'est mieux que l'année dernière ça
s'est plutôt ne s'en est plutôt bien
sorti klein à rien moi j'étais avec ma
styliste la delphine tout à l'heure qui
était dans ma loge elle m'a dit qu'elle
avait adoré cette édition la trouvais
qu'elle était top alors ici là qu'ils
disent oui il y en a qui disent non il
ya eu une loi c'est la pire que ça alors
pour lewis est la pire l'énoncé pas la
pire alors déjà il ya eu un truc
une première question tf1 elle a dit que
c'était en direct les nrj music au
regard d anne claire coudray à la fin du
jt de 20h disait ça sur tf1 ne manquez
pas la 22e édition des nrj music awards
présentés évidemment par nikos aliagas
émission qui a lieu en direct à la scène
musicale avec
émission qui a lieu en direct
[Musique]
oui non alors ses rivaux directs aglio
maintenant ils ont mis de quatre jours
pour enregistrer la cérémonie notamment
à cause du coup victime à quatre jours
en direct
non une petite partie en direct mais il
ya eu quatre jours avec des prestations
je crois qu'il ya eu près de 58
prestation au total est bonne pour pas
qu'ils aient trop de monde sur le
plateau pour éviter qu'ils aient trop de
rassemblement ils ont étalé sa sur
quatre jours donc on s'était pas en
direct
d'accord oui oui maintenant j'en ai plus
mercredi en fait parce qu'ils pouvaient
pas dépasser la jauge pour le personnel
pour respecter l'accord légal et donc
c'est normal hein c'est pas leur côté la
pire c'est plutôt une visière fait mal
mais je sais mais j'allais dire mikos
nikos ou nico s'il n'a pas parlé une
seule fois en direct quand il a il s'est
gratté mené les tons directs mais pas
avec nous ce soir il n'est pas là ce
soir maintenant ça s'est fini à 19
heures il y avait personne à 22 heures
ni à 23 heures on va en parler parce que
ma qu'il était sur les 2 sur les deux
donzelles oui mais le score de toute
façon il est miraculeux s'il ya une
quasiment un million c'est pas vrai le
téléspectateur mais ce que disait maths
il a raison c'est un endroit ils font ce
métier pour leur public nous c'est vrai
que des artistes qui reçoivent un prix
sans public autour d'eux c'est quand
même un peu hard en plus les applause
faire la presse que la deuxième question
c'est y at il eu du plagiat aux nrj
music awards comme ce 4 8l où beaucoup
de téléspectateurs ont affirmé qu'ils
eurent plagiat aux nrj music awards
la prestation d'ouverture de gims qui
était auparavant c'est un super pote sur
le toit de la scène musicale
ressemblerait comme deux gouttes d'eau à
la prestation de the week end à
l'équivalent des nma aux états unis les
vm à regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors voilà alors d'in the gimp lui il
est pas m'étendre il a une orientation
ims il va dire on recule on l'a dit
chante sur le toit il a trouvé ça
magnifique et moi je suis pas d'accord
c'est donc la pape il n'y a pas du tout
plagiat parce que ça n'est pas la même
chanson
pas d'accord voilà vous faites ce que
vous voulez mais l'important c'est que
c'est beau c'est bon sens voire je pense
que voilà à mon avis cette prestation de
ce week-end est connu mais à un moment
on arrive à on a fait tellement de
presta dans tous les sens dans toutes
les cérémonies du monde que forcément il
ya toujours quelqu'un qui va s'inspirer
d'un a tient les tenues à la cet endroit
pour le faire sur le toit d'un truc bon
l'important c'est que c'était beau pour
une nouvelle une ouverture c'est
impressionnant alors nicolas ce genre
d'émission elle doit être absolument en
direct l'événement c'est les paillettes
le derrière et là pour le coup il ya eu
huit heures en direct et avec la crise
adore faire il fallait pas faire
l'émission champs et par contre ils ont
eu raison de pomper une excellente idée
mais non est ce que ca de lier bas il
était de faire des paillettes avec
pascal et moi je suis pas d'accord avec
toi nico parce qu'à un moment donné
quand tu vois que le cérémonial va pas
avoir le même ka-shing d'habitude parce
qu'il ya pas de public parce qu'il
manque des choses parce que c'est en
différé et c est bon ont fait au moins
des efforts pour l'argent sur convoi
slimane évita oui moi je trouve que
c'est un tableau extraordinairement bien
fait mais après pour le reste on copie
pas les gens maintenant changer d'avis
bien aussi mais les gens y avait des
connecteurs il y avait des corps il faut
savoir que chaque année il ya des
numéros qui sont enregistrés en avance
sur un ou deux jours iliad qui peut pas
être la forme c'est les absorbeurs bien
sûr il ya des mecs qui doivent chez pays
doivent regarder un autre catégorie
je reconnais comme j'étais beaucoup sur
le téléthon je veux que par
intermittence mais plus maintenant mais
on parle de salles à dieu merci les
masses je suis pas aux états unis donc
moi honnêtement l'un des trucs que j'ai
préféré c'est précisément maître gims y
laissa a été copiée ça vous dérange
non ça me dérange pas du tout d'accord
claire oui bizarre que les années mais
ils ont quand même l'ambition d'être une
cérémonie internationale il était
d'ailleurs à un moment il y avait bien
deux c'est à une époque et pharrell
williams et mais devrait l'intéresser
venir il ya toujours de grands artistes
et je trouve que plagier une séquence
qui était diffusée en plus il ya
quelques mois à la télé américaine je
trouve qu'en termes ne signale c'est pas
très fort ils ont un an pour préparer la
série
les révolte ça a été dur à d'ailleurs
assure ça ils ont ils ont avec personne
n'a pu venir mais les autres années on
les avait pas non plus la dernière
grande cérémonie on va dire que c'était
2007 jean les cérémonies en 2012 quoi
encore vous avez fait il ya eu rihanna
katy perry rihanna et katy perry
[Musique]
il ya eu richard ouimet un truc un truc
aussi évident c'est que la cérémonie est
le plus d'artistes américains ça reste
une des pires audiences mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai il a raison parce
qu'ils font l'audience en france c'est
l'aisance et on sait qu'ils sont et je
vous dirais qu'il y avait les américains
faisait de l'audience
j'aurais pris des chroniqueurs
américains et ben voilà c'est bon là
c'est clair je fais avec mon temps je
veux des français vous comprenez des
français bon bah c'est pas compliqué oui
la chérie bien d'autres trucs aussi
qu'elle gênait comme céline qui dit
j'essaie d'écouter des artistes chanter
mais je reste focus sur les faux cris du
public en salle et découverts avant
c'est à dire j'ai fini le téléthon donc
je suis allé voir sa sert a lancé obama
presta comment elle avait été filmée et
tout est là je dis mais attendez et
j'entends les applause ça criait tout en
plus cette salade et ça crie mais c'est
sûr qu'à réparsac ouvre la voie et tout
sur camille lellouche est vraiment
malade je kiffe le titre d'ailleurs oui
produit par mon ami jean rachid non
c'est là ils y sont allés en électrique
sébastien loeb toujours en les rappels
je ne sais pas qui était le mec derrière
ça mais il n'a pas d'oreille
quitter l'eau que je suis sûr de moi tu
te donne tout ce que j'ai alors c'est
croire moi que tu es
je te
je t'aime
jamais dit attends tu vas voir l'amour
c'était un peu sceptique ça élimine ça
brille ça réchauffe ça pique les yeux
alors c'est un support alors ça c'est
insupportable et joue il ya un truc
énorme qui est très très très très très
très drôle c'est que il ya quelqu'un qui
à shazam et voilà sa télé et en fait ça
correspond à des rires des internautes
ils ont fait 13 ans ont pris une musique
d'applause sur youtube les mecs ne se
sont pas fait chier du tout ça s'appelle
school auditorium cross up close and
sharing
encore aujourd'hui il est même dans son
petit chat un train de regarder on va le
voir regarder et en fait ils ont juste
pris ça pour mai et ruch je vous jure
que c'est vrai le mec à shazam et et
c'est ça c'est un truc sur youtube j'ai
dû comme quoi c'est donc un truc voilà
si la musique d'applause sur youtube
c'est énorme en plus c'était jamais ni
au bon moment couplé d'un coup de gueule
fx magnifique on lui a mis une sorte
d'app losc ont décalé on fait cela
n'avait aucun sens mais c'était tout le
temps et on l'a vu samedi donc la
gestion des nrj music awards a été un
petit peu too much sur les bruitages
d'une mission après quelques recherches
donc on a découvert qu'ils avaient aussi
travaillé pour d'autres émissions turbo
hélène et les garçons et même
communal
[Applaudissements]
et les minables qui sont là je crois que
cherche la bagarre aujourd'hui que ces
espaces
je vais vous présenter ici la 205 gti 60
chevaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voulais revenir aux audiences qu'il y
avait 5 millions et ya des
téléspectateurs qui font des bonnes des
bonnes interventions qui disent
attention c'était en face du téléthon et
on va le dire à ma le téléthon c'est une
formidable opération et on est tous
derrière le téléthon je vous le dis et
bravo ma puisque tu étais le parrain du
téléthon on va reparler dans un instant
mais c'est vrai que il ya plein de gens
je vous le dis tu en trouves et honteux
que les nrj music awards se mettre en
face des trous n'y a pas grand chose en
fasse exprès pour donner ce fait ça mais
là à ce que le téléthon va le dire
nicolas pernikoff on sait quand tombe le
téléthon dont tout le monde sait que
c'est le 4 et 5 décembre
voilà c'est le vent premier vendredi du
mois de décembre donc mine de rien il ya
plein de gens qui disent c'est honteux
d'avoir mis les nrj music loire en face
du téléthon alors ils ne font plus que
miss france et ça je vous dit jean
pierre foucault a beaucoup beaucoup
oeuvré pour que ce soit plus en phase du
téléthon jean pierre qui est mon frère
mon ami mon ami il a vraiment voulu que
ça soit plus en phase du téléthon miss
france
il a vraiment devrait énormément pour ça
l'ambiance et c'est vrai que là je
trouve nicolas pernikoff chasse est
d'accord avec les téléspectateurs je
trouve ça un peu gênant pour les miss
rangez vous répondre je trouve ça bien
moins d'avoir les miss france en face
puisque comme vous le savez le téléthon
c'est une émission sans fin d'accord
entre et à n'importe quel moment sur
l'émission de toute façon c'est pas une
émission qui va scorer
by par contre les miss france qui font
toujours les audiences extraordinaires
tayrac des pics d'audience et il arrive
et un jean pierre foucault qui a
toujours été mais extraordinaire en
revenant permanence les dons a fait que
dans ces moments là
le téléthon a eu les meilleures a eu les
records de non non je suis pas d'accord
parce que si vous mettez une émission en
face qui va faire j'en sais rien mais
quand ils sont allés nrj award ça me
dérange parce que c'est pas en direct
et puis parce que c'est pas une émission
forcément qui va appeler qui va amener
les dons supplémentaires mais les miss
france qui est une émission populaire
qui ratisse hyper large quand ça fait
ces pics d'audience et que vous allez
jean pierre foucault qui dit attention
il se rappelle qu'il faut envoyer vos
dons au téléthon ça a de la gueule et ça
marche
mais moi je vais aller dans l'autre sens
parce que si tu dis qu'ils ont mis les
nrj music awards en face du téléthon ça
ne se fait pas si c'était moi je vais te
dire
ça se fait pas de mettre mon jeu ville
qui cartonne on sait très bien que mon
jeu vivendi tout balancer les 5
pourquoi ils savaient très bien que ça
allait faire cinq ans il se bat avec
france 2 fallait pas mettre mon film est
là me fallait mettre autre chose de
moins selon mongi ben si c'est vrai mais
pas du tout il aurait s'il avait mis en
inédit mais je redis oui là c'est par là
c'est une rediffusion ce que vous aviez
l'air de dire quelque chose que ça avait
asséché du coup les invités parce que
ceux qui chantaient aux nma ne pouvait
pas être en même temps sur le terrain
alors je sais pas si c'était une règle
mais en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il y avait
plus de bien sûr présents au mma le
vendredi soir que le samedi après
ouais j'ai faim je pense que c'est miss
france on regarde pour les mises pour le
défilé pour découvrir qui est notre
favori
le téléthon on va pour les histoires de
chaque famille etc mais aussi à les
artistes qui viennent ponctuellement
régulièrement sur le show et c'est vrai
que d'avoir une émission où il ya tous
les artistes en face c'est un peu dur
comme alors il ya aussi certains
internautes
voilà qui ont pas qui fait la prestation
de nikos voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez regarder petit compile né sous
une bonne étoile c'est un papa heureux
c'est matt pokora gas salut nikos qui ne
manquait aussi cette année
vous nous avez fait danser avec les
tubes incroyable
un vrai scoop
la franchise est allé j'ai à te revoir
photo max rosereau max 15 décembre ce
défaut si les bars et ses nomades voter
par téléphone au 39 4 bien 4 allez
petite photo souvenir des trois eaux là
bravo et merci bien lire que ça lui est
une tannée pour nico public doit être
très très compliqué je vous nagez
d'emploi vous donner il ya deux trois
ans nrj avait proposé à tf1 de m oui à
la présentation des nrj music awards et
f1 qui est diffuseur a refusé a voulu
conserver nikko ce qu'il considère comme
étant le meilleur sur la chaîne des
sillons nicolas pernikoff qui était
directeur des divertissements nikos pour
vous c'est la bonne personne
non moi je mettrais un animateur
d'énergie d'abord parce que ce serait
logique c'est quand même énergie jean
piat la télé nrj awards donc oui comment
donc sonné j'aurais mis qu il faut
savoir que c'est un ca a été créée en
1996 les ça s'appelait à l'époque les
djeuns d'or et cet effet à locker
vision des 30 ans du mythe
pm puisque c'est le midem multipliées
tout
ou à l'époque mais là en look
il est
c'est la troisième année ou quatrième
année que nikos est complètement paumé
génération rendez compte de l'émission
et vous rendez compte de l'émission qui
est obligé de fermer c'est la sauce
derrière c'est un enfer et je dis oui
comment s'est passée en plus a été
tourné aux quatre jours à venir que les
artistes et public c'est qu'on est vrai
qu'ils sont pas là moi je la laisse
qu'ils n'ont pas pour l'instant si l'on
lui laisser une deuxième chance encore
la dernière chance l'année prochaine
pour moi c'est ma pire expérience un
jeune et je sais je sais que camille
combal a dit qu'il aimerait bien prendre
la place de nikos une fois qu'ils en
auraient marre voilà un ouvrage entre on
verra on verra en tout cas c'est
vraiment vous vous l'avez fait que les
poches des années mais une fois c'est
mon pire souvenir la division plus elle
est vraiment du plu c'était en direct
c'était à calmer alors c'est un enfer
absolue russe et c'est un bordel public
et lahi ce jour là pour le coup est dur
pour le vrai mais annoncer franchement
c'est une bien pour moi c'est de pire
animer ces voix là les artistes sont là
mais franchement ils sont ils sont très
stressés il vous écoute peu ou pas ils
n'ont pas le temps de répéter enfin
bravo c'est compliqué alors il ya eu
aussi alerte enlèvement où sont les
stars la marionnette c'est plus cohérent
mdr ya plus qu'une star internationale
qui dure depuis longtemps même drc
éclaté quand même alors même si on adore
les téléspectateurs
voilà qui adore vita slimane gims
vianney moi aussi je l'écris fin c'est
que des potes et je suis très content
qu'ils sont repartis avec eux avec plein
de prix au détail slimane sont des
chanteurs qu'on retrouve dans beaucoup
d'autres émissions et c'est vrai qu'il
n'ya pas eu cette année le petit plus
des nrj music awards regardez on vous a
fait une évolution de la cérémonie et
dans trois ans je pense que ce sera ma
tante la grosse recette
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout est papa ou té papa ou t elle au
quotidien
oui mais encore
temps
[Musique]
voilà 2021 je pense qu'on aura des verts
le frelon voilà et y en a de plus en
plus vides à pau qui laisse des magnétos
où on vous a fait une petite compil des
gens pas là et c'est vrai qu'elle est
assez longue
regardez sur trône encore bon semble
encore bonsoir mes pompes
et bah tu n'es pas là ce soir mariah
carey est en duplex avec nous depuis los
angeles me qui le dépasse j'aimerais
vraiment être avec vous ce soir pour
fêter ça agresseurs elton john
bonsoir et merci les black eyed peas
salut paris lady gaga et rihanna
[Applaudissements]
il ya un truc qu'il faut qu'il faut
juste comprendre alors si le point
commun tous les années c'est que j'étais
depuis toutes ces années j'ai vu j'ai vu
les cérémonies tout j'étais toute la
cantine avec beyoncé madonna britney
spears une année le truc c'est qu'on est
dans une industrie qui a perdu
énormément d'argent depuis 20 ans donc
faire venir
beyoncé aux nrj awards c'est à coups de
152 500 euros pour la maison de disques
sauf que les artistes américains faut
savoir une chose c'est qu'ils ne vendent
pas beaucoup de disques en france entre
universal music qui va faire venir
rihanna ils vont dépenser le jet le
machin à cannes les 25 danseurs ça va
leur coûter 300 mille caprices dix mille
albums derrière il a un truc c'est que
c'est que l'industrie est la plus les
mots pour faire venir ses stars là tout
simplement
franchement on n'aura pas meilleure
explication non voilà la personne de la
terre est en vous d'une je trouve être
bien sympa
c'est comme lorsque nous on est vraiment
un pull un pays particulier c'est que
les artistes américains ne vendent pas
beaucoup d'albums en france les grandes
stars lauriad temps en temps l'exception
bruno mars quand le sujet et c'est mémé
beyoncé en france et 50 mille albums sur
les derniers macbook aura là on n'a pas
de pokora mais même en terme d'audience
ça marche moins bien ça vous fait plus
en faisant vita et slimane qui en
faisant du smi leur métier là tout à
l'heure quand il m'a parlé des ventes
france mais on arrive unique très
particulier c'est pas comme l'angleterre
où il vient de signer en train de faire
sa mise en france de chypre pur les
américains représentent pas tant que ça
dans le marché beaucoup d'internautes
ont été très étonnés aussi lors d'un
duplex avec mariah carey s'est vainement
de l'icône internationale ça quand vous
donnez lewarde de l'icône internationale
c'est qu'avec est arrivée dans le bureau
d'énergie musique aura qui allie les
gars on à mariah carey wayne mc a ôté
son petit bateau elsa pourquoi eh ben on
n'a qu'à créer un award manicon atallah
cela s'est fait à les laver ses mains
il a démarré car et c'est pas qu'on
foute vendu les données publiées pour
qu'elles fassent le duplex h coach
comment ça se passe elle était en mode
diva donc gauche il parfait pyjama
spéciale
noël jolie canaris joli sapin elle est
au top en maille dieu bénisse a refait
tout était parfait un détail près
regardez c'est assez dark as un
photographe qui a vu ça puisque bien à
quelquechose qui disparaît c'est le jeu
des sept erreurs roman de guiron sauveur
de vous avoir avec le corset 22e nrj
music award maria vous fêté cette année
vos trente ans de carrière pour célébrer
l'événement maria vous fêté cette année
de 30 ans de carrière pour célébrer
l'événement chien a disparu pourquoi
musique
ils ont fait du montage mais ils ont
fait des montages crois que c'était
effectivement alive et comme d'études
vont couper dedans c'est pas très malin
c'est exactement arrière à la face à
roanne n'est pas terrible le montage est
aujourd'hui accès direct et pire la
vérité sur les chiffres
autre absent de la cérémonie sayah
nakamura d'ailleurs je les appelais
jeudi à losail à mékhé pas ça mais que
vous foutez pas là ll était voilà elle a
remporté le world de l'artiste féminine
francophone de l'année mais n'a pas
voulu se déplacer pour récupérer son
prix elle nous a fait une petite vidéo
comme mariah carey ont fait tout le
monde a fait des vidéos et un espace
temps tout est la gagnante et aya
nakamura
à ganac à bois pour chaque enfant dans
laquelle consécration à la maison jaune
remercier toutes les personnes qui ont
voté qu'à moi merci énergie merci à
nikos tu me ramènera des trophées plus
tard et voilà
salut
excuse moi palais
mais voilà alors est en revanche elle
est inerte cérémonie mme en espagne
parce qu'on espagne zaballa n'a qu'un
mois
regardez l été voilà parce qu'elle a
pris elle a remporté le prix de la
révélation internationale de l'année
ouais d'oceania nakamura
merci à l'austro lenta pour le world je
suis hyper contente et la sias encore
une fois la naca morales a quand même
vendu 1 million d'albums dans le monde
avec son dernier album dont 500000 en
france et noria bhl de l'avoir dénigrer
son public français comme ça mais c'est
le daily mail
regardez comment alizon il a su
prononcer mais n'a même pas su prononcer
son nom là de ses régions eh oui c'est
une ak oublier les bars vous quand je
vais vous appelez ça des travaux gpl est
filmé pour la récompenser ce permis à l
apéritif en france pour la france et à
l'italie
mais moi je suis pas d'accord bah oui
alors déjà un regard d une petite
mignonne vengeance parce qu'avec tous
cas c'est pris dans la gueule avec cette
histoire baisser l'année d'après elle
invité en espagne business is business
elle fait aussi son son son buzz dans le
monde entier donc y en a pour tous les
pays
je veux dire c'est pas cracher dans la
gueule des gens elle leur rend à sa
manière et c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
la jambe et l'autre nourrir ghana pays
acamac amour
il ya une bonne question de pascal
persie passe quatre mois c'est un truc
qui m'a vexé c'est papa pourra aussi
parce que j'avais des chances et le
matin rapport à ce qui s'est passé avec
matt environ et ça ça m'a énormément
quand on connaît son parcours je
trouvais ça l'a envahie cavaliers on va
rappeler eu un truc il y en a qu à moi
ouais c'est ça oui
écoute l'améliorant qu'en fait là où
elle fait fausse route c'est alors après
que qu'elle mérite ça il ya aucun
problème
moi je pense que juste là où elle a fait
une erreur c'est quand elle parle de top
10 moi c'est ça c'est quoi le streaming
dans le top10 streaming j'y suis pas
mais par contre je vendais par contre le
top-10 physique je suis important c'est
ça le top 10 de retourner j'y suis
depuis 17 ans donc en fait cia est en
fait il faut il ya juste deux
générations la qui s'opposent en fait
entre guillemets c'est à une opposition
de d'un public d'une génération qui a
commencé en 2003 et un public qui est là
depuis trois ans qui est très stream
le problème d'un du public streaming
c'est aussi beaucoup de touristes c'est
des gens qui n'achètent pas forcément
ils ont invoqué
c'est le buzz du moment donc elle a
beaucoup de gens qui l'écoutent ça c'est
fait des études elle cartonne c'est une
certitude mais quand on vend 500 mille
albums dont les trois quarts sont en
streaming
on peut pas garantir que ces 400
millions de fidèles qui vont voter à
d'acteurs mois quand j'en ai trois cent
mille j'en ai trois cent mille qui
s'amusent comme des brutes en fait c'est
pas une question de qui cartonne le plus
c'est le public le plus motivé le clown
zac mairie caresser ou pas du tout non
parce que manger les gens ont besoin de
justifier non après 17 arrêts de
chiffres que je fais ou pas
on